ladies and gentlemen dan patrick
everybody hey
please take a seat sir thanks for coming
dp can i have your shirt dan you do
no he says can i you want can i have
your shirt that happened a long time ago
you've done it is that a call
are you gonna go call back on dan
patrick as he sits down
why not
okay somebody to take off my shirt
we have taken a shirtless picture
together before also yes yes people so
many callbacks
why are you making this about you and i
wouldn't take my shirt off what did i do
i'm not making it about me it's about
us rich a moment for us
i
no i had my shirt off somebody had their
pants off in this room
uh yes that would be mike delta yes did
not take his shirt off for the photo he
didn't want to dj mikey well that's how
i proved you i would i but he said i i
won't take my shirt off but i will take
my pants off and i said sure
sounds like a win-win
how are you doing dan i'm good good to
see you yeah it's good to be glad to be
back here why don't you get here
saturday okay what is today yeah i know
right it's monday you know uh yes
saturday but it was good you know went
down to venice beach
just did a drive-by okay well i know you
you rollerblade don't you i
i i have rollerblade
i know that so but um did you do that i
did not like
like fletch back in the day
i don't rollerblade you know it was
brought to my attention i should
probably not rollerblade anymore
and uh
my son says you embarrassed the family
that thank you
but my daughters think it's pretty cool
but my wife said you know i think i
think we've outgrown the rollerblading
thing so you didn't pack the
rollerblades for i did not but you can
rent them down at venice speech but i
went down there and uh i wanted to watch
some pickup basketball
oh and uh
it was it was so funny because there's
always the guy who's waiting for an nba
scout to come by
he just you know it's like you go to
karaoke and thinking simon cowell's
going to show up and say this is los
angeles um and this guy was dribbling
behind his back he was doing it so the
guy guarding him is not moving because
the guy's not moving he's just dribbling
behind his back dribbling behind his
back dribbling on his back and the
defensive guy is just going
like come on
and he makes the shot and then he starts
to flat this is on the the courts at
venice beach there's a dj there
who's
you're confirming there's a dj yeah
because dan patrick is here and by the
way dan patrick you're in the rich house
georgia terrestrial radar
so i'm sorry so you're out of and i
watch this with great fascination
that
these guys all think they can play
and some can but they're they're they're
auditioning you know that for like an
and one mixtape that could just break
out at any moment here and you're going
no don't do it don't do it but
did anybody have game anybody yeah there
were a couple of guys that had game
but
there's some bad basketball
you know any white men who did in fact
jump uh
no no there was there was one guy
a left-hander at a headband like bad bad
outfits too
like you just like if you can't play at
least look like you can play these guys
couldn't play and then the way they
dressed and
uh then you had this guy with a headband
a left-hander and he kept taking these
shots
not even hitting iron sometime like you
have to guys getting banged in the head
underneath the hoop and
but uh yes i spent a good portion of the
afternoon being entertained at venice
beach speaking about outfits dan patrick
here on the rich eisen show did
i see
on your show to kick off super bowl week
here in los angeles will ferrell in a
tiger outfit did he show up in a full
bengal
no he just did his face he painted his
face in the bengal colors okay i only
saw a head shot
okay yeah and so um
there it is
okay
and that's a bobby gritch
patch on his on his jacket
in honor of one of the great
second
angels of all time i went gosh you know
so there there's the bobby grits patch
i've been looking for i i just was like
wow okay he gave a lot of thought to
okay the patch and then of course the
makeup yeah and uh he said that the rams
broke his heart
when they left therefore he has never
forgiven them oh my and he's rooting for
the bengals he didn't strike me as a
grudge holder dan i'll be honest with
you i think he's sneaky mean
sneaky gradual i think he is a sneaky
prick
we put that down for a fantasy team
he's such a generous guy he truly is
he's a he's a true generous person so
well generosity is also to show up to a
show
like yeah
and it's just like that he's going to
come next level
and and i imagine like he wouldn't let
you see him beforehand and just had a
stroll out and you had to just and i i
wanted it i wanted the natural reveal
and he got in there an hour before he
was going on and he said i'm going to be
in the back if you just leave me alone
and i said
good
and they came out with his
bengal colors on
now for you though i mean um were you a
bengal guy growing up i grew up in
zanesville ohio right and we got the
that's when they had the cleveland
browns we didn't have the bengals then
then we moved to
a small town outside of cincinnati mason
and then
the bengals came to town
and i remember seeing
bob trumpy play sure bruce coslett play
sure
um
the bengals came in and had greg cook
who was rookie of the year quarterback
then got hurt
and we used to sneak into the games they
played at the university of cincinnati
and i remember the first game i saw the
chargers came to town
and those uniforms sure so you had the
bengal uniforms that were horrible
and the chargers came out and i went oh
my god this is this is great
and i love john hadel and dickie post
and lance allworth
and i was in love with those colors and
every time i see the chargers when they
wear those colors i'm like
brings back memories of of going to see
them but yeah i got to see a lot of
uh we used to go to games to see the
teams coming in from out of town yeah so
it wasn't like i was a die-hard bengal
fan but then you know i started covering
them when i covered the bengals
from a distance when i was working in
dayton uh when chris collinsworth was a
rookie
and i remember collinsworth after every
home game
i went right to his locker because he
was the clocker he was he was gold he
was always great
and uh
you know he well he's still the same you
know a talker but they were anthony
munoz i was able to be around i went to
the coldest football game in history
game against the chargers the chargers
oh my god if you could have if i bet
back then
or i had money back then when the
chargers came out of the tunnel and the
bengals offensive linemen like max
montoya
they had they were sleeveless
and if you could have seen the chargers
faces if you could have said hey you
guys are going to lose by like a field
goal but you can go right back in the
tunnel get on the plane and go home
they probably would have went okay yeah
that's we'll take our we will take our
chances going back home and not playing
in this game because they had no chance
it was
it was it made you cry if you could cry
you couldn't because your tears would
freeze up yeah but if you could have
cried that day with the weather you
would have it was no kidding it was they
should never have played that football
game really oh my god
windshield factor yeah
i knew a cameraman you know and your
cameraman has to have
you know the the fingers got to be there
for the k he
lost his
pinky it frostbite
had to have it taken off
for shooting the game wow damn it was
that cool and then they
and then they made the super bowl and
saw montana there and then they made
another super bowl saw montana there but
they at least played
competitive yes both of those super
bowls they really took the niners you
know to the end and you know give credit
to montana um
you know even the game in detroit when
they lost to to montana they they at
least
and it was weird i was watching the
chiefs game and it was 21-3
and my wife goes you're going to watch i
said i just don't want them embarrassed
because i i don't root for the bengals i
don't root against them i root for the
the people of cincinnati who
whenever i would say i was from
cincinnati somebody would they would
always go all the bungles always first
thing i'd say oh the bungles right and
you go yeah the bungles
and they you know they finally got their
quarterback and they they got some magic
here and i just didn't want him
embarrassed against kansas city and it
was
painful then i would just check my phone
and then my wife would go just go watch
it and i go like i can't and then it was
2110 and i go okay
we're not going to get blown out and
then my wife goes you said we i go ah
there you go and then i i went down and
all of a sudden i'm watching and i it
went into overtime and i'd walk away and
my wife goes wait isn't this important i
go yes tell me what happens so that it
was it came back to
i was a fan again and and when i started
at sportscenter i gave up being a fan
because i i thought it was only fair if
i
was covering the steelers sure that i
was going to be fair to the steelers
instead of somebody saying he's a bengal
fan dan patrick here hour two coming up
hour three coming up but keep going dan
okay no don't keep going okay i'm sorry
i'm saying i'm saying goodbye to the
radio audience oh you guys no no they're
already gone they're gonna keep going
i'm sorry we're going i'm just thrilled
i'm just
i'm not trying to just trying to just
trying to do my job i'm not allowed to
touch the trophy um i have these here
you know i don't wear those gloves
[Laughter]
yeah because i've gotten in trouble
no no i i i i had these here and i
mentioned before as you were on your way
over here that the the trophy's here
and that you you've touched it before
you haven't handed it out yeah okay and
that i didn't say hey gotta wear white
gloves no because you're handing it to
the winner you know
so well when the guy brings out the
stanley cup he has the white gloves on
the nfl just doesn't i don't know this
is here just in case and uh i i
definitely said you would you would
touch it because you feel compelled to
do it and plus you know what makes me
uncomfortable
so i find you laughing at that because
you know that's probably true that i
find it makes me well here's the thing
when they say you handed out the trophy
i didn't hand out the trophy because i
didn't hold the trophy to hand the
trophy
so you've never handled this trophy
before i've been on the the podium right
with said trophy
but that trophy the commissioner it they
i think they put it up on a little
whatever pedestal yeah and the
commissioner then gives it to the owner
or something but
my job the first time i did it joe
namath was coming up
and you know through all of these people
and they're all touching the trophy and
and uh they get up to the podium and you
know i'm trying to interview the
commissioner i'm trying to communicate
with the commissioner of what what he
needs to say and what i'm going to say
and i introduce you and then i hand you
the mic
those kind of things so i'm up there for
the presentation of the trophy but not
actually handing out the it sounds more
impressive when you hand out the trophy
and i don't correct people normally but
with you i can't
joining me here for another segment is
uh one of my favorites i've uh known
this man for a long time i don't even
know how to introduce you the host of
the dan patrick show that precedes us on
nbc sports on peacock every single day
as well as on nbc sports audio serious
xm channel 85. good to see you dp good
to see you
how are the kids by the way we are
everybody's good good everybody's good
we're we're gonna take uh we're gonna
take i think we're gonna leave tay at
home this week my eight-year-old
daughter sophie have you been in so fast
it is um are you staying for the game or
you're not i'm not okay because i had to
do the show on monday morning you got to
get back home yes um it is a beautiful
stadium but for a kid it is sensory
overload like it is a wipeout that
they don't watch the game they watch
this they watch the screen above the
stadium it's like when you go to a
cowboy game exactly when when i was the
first time it was in that stadium it was
for that super bowl where aaron rodgers
and the packers won and beat the
steelers i remember thinking to myself
i'm watching the game on the screen i'm
like how lucky am i to be at a super
bowl look at the damn people on the
field like what are you doing but you
just stare at that thing and so but
anyway we're gonna we're you know we're
gonna take uh coop and zan how are your
kids
they're all good they're all good
i had
the packer fan my son
got crushed
but my daughters
don't have any interest other than that
it was in la and they would love to go
to la and i said no shut it down i need
a little bit more uh evidence that you
care about football you got to tighten
the rotation for the playoffs that's
what we're doing in our household you've
got to tighten the rotation yeah like
riley
to win a champion
my middle daughter said uh hey i'd love
to go to the super bowl i said who's in
it
she goes
two teams
okay
okay this sounds like the movie diner
like
yeah yeah you got a quiz in the basement
you gotta pass the quiz at least get to
the title here and and you know what my
wife doesn't know sports but that's i
love that she doesn't know sports
because i come home and it's not like
she'll go hey
how about that brady news and i'm like i
you know it's we talk about a lot of
other things and
my daughters don't follow sports
but then they blame me now
because they'll meet boys who want to
talk sports but then they don't know
sports so they why do they blame you
because i didn't somehow expose them to
sports or you didn't want to force it
down there no i i gave them that
opportunity and they had no interest but
you know i'm these these guys who
ask them out on dates think that they
know sportscenter certainly when they
find out who dad is i mean and plus you
can also you know
i don't know you can say to your kids
there's a little show called
sportscenter you know that i used to be
on and
um yeah find it on youtube yeah um
it's kind of silly that this news is
breaking right now and it's something
i'm sure you'll be talking about on your
show tomorrow it's crazy how in this
21st century
people gather news or glean news from
who's
unfollowing anybody on all of their
social media accounts but apparently
what 15 minutes ago that somebody
noticed was someone noticed this last
night last night
so this quarterback guys played in the
pro bowl
was having an mvp type year you may have
heard of him
kyler murray
scrubbed everything cardinals related
from his instagram page
1.3 million followers what's up with
that
you know like how do you glean
from this other than the fact that what
like what is he unhappy once a house
what they've given him everything
doesn't like cliff's offense oh you're
now you're just now you're just stirring
the pot you don't know well yeah no i
don't know anything for sure but like
can you make it all of a sudden he's
gone and deleted all his pictures and
everything that he had to do with the
cardinals that's specific
that takes doing was this after he threw
the pick six in the pro bowl that he
decided to do that it was noticed last
night did he
did he blame the offensive coordinator
in the pro bowl possible
i don't know i mean i obviously i had my
famous infamous run in with him
at the super bowl in atlanta when
he just sat there and didn't answer any
questions that's because he was put out
in front of the media by whatever
whoever he was gatorade yeah right
and he had yet to announce whether he
was going to play football or baseball
and
we had a similar thing because we were
in this town hall from you yeah and i i
here's a crazy thing is he came to us
first we pre-taped him and then he was
on your show we warmed him up for you he
was warmed up
dan we warmed him up
and sent him down the hallway already
talked he was already in the business of
talking
and that happened and then all of a
sudden it goes viral
what he was doing what he was doing on
your show and we're like well get
get ready for us to plus press play on
this thing later on he wouldn't say a
word no and i about all right remember
talking to uh
two nfl teams two people who worked with
two different teams and they said it
made them
like reconsider
you know his draft status right even
though they thought okay you'll probably
go number one
but that personality scared them that
you know he wasn't talking and why
wasn't he talking and
somehow it became
that teams took that interview right if
you want to call it an interview
and because they're always looking for
somebody loved the game somebody a
leader somebody red flag communicator
yeah they're always looking for
something it's uh you know what's the
red flag he didn't answer dan patrick's
questions
we're not taking him
but i you know he's
i i subsequently had an interview with
him where he made fun of that
he was you know he had personality he
made fun of it what else can you do
after that right i mean yeah so but i i
don't know if
you know wasn't cliff his guy and i
guess so and and the crazy thing is is
that you know
usually when you're drafted first just
ask matthew stafford okay
i mean ask matthew stafford is now in
year 13 he's finally making it to the
super bowl had to go in and
have a you know an epiphany moment and
share it with his wife
as a group as a family then decide yeah
we are going to press the button of i
want out of here we want out of here
and it's emotional it's so tough and he
did it just ask him how long it takes
how many people get de'andre hopkins and
the aj green and you know james connor
and have all of these folks around you
let's add wat i mean there i don't know
what this could be you have to view that
something pissed him off i mean for to
cleanse the account an account like that
i mean you could have somebody do it but
at least it's the decision to do it
because you know people are going to
read into it but he still has his
oakland a's account so oh my word i
better
start to look for it no i mean because
he's not following the card
how about this though like let's just
say this
you add him to the mix of wanting out
and add him to the mix of the
quarterback carousel
what happens then you know what i'm
saying i mean you want to add him
what do you do with that information
because the cardinals wouldn't do
anything like that and what like
i don't know
well i still wonder if
you know matthew stafford was going to
end up with carolina
and carolina would not be in the super
bowl this week though it would not be
but
i mean you look at these things that
something happens or it didn't happen
and then what the end result would be
you know the rams go all in and stafford
you know you don't want to be the bad
guy you want the team to say you know
what we're it's a mutual yeah parting
this
that you know benefits the lions and
matthew has given all of this it's like
seattle's going to come to this uh fork
in the road with russell wilson because
i think russ is going to ask the
seahawks to
do for him what the lions did for
matthew stafford
like
you guys are going in a different
direction at my age i you know i want to
i want to play for somebody else or this
where i want to play
and you don't want to be the bad guy
because i don't i don't know this but i
don't think russ
and pete carroll
that you want to you know continue to
try to make that work uh because i think
it hasn't worked i think it's worked
sometimes because of and in spite of and
i could see russ going you know what
let me go i'm going to cost you this
amount of money let me go i want to play
someplace else and it goes back to the
super bowl where he was the walter
payton man of the year watching mahomes
and brady playing a super bowl he's like
what am i doing here i was about to say
that we'll know he's unhappy if he you
book him for the tuesday after this
show but you know
what's interesting about that is
we were going to have him on friday of
super bowl of super bowl week okay and
he couldn't do it but he said i promise
when i get back to the super bowl i'll
do it
well we didn't get him monday and then
he said you know i'll do tuesday
well because he was there at super bowl
watching mahomes and brady i think it
just
reinstalled that yeah what am i doing
here well they showed a shot of him in
the comments miserable miserable
miserable he's a walter payton man of
the year which is the most prestigious
honor you can get yeah in many ways you
know obviously mvp is one thing but this
is viewed by so many people as you get a
patch there's no mvp patch on your on
your jersey but i think
i think he's looking at now now it's my
legacy i've been in two i've won one
i'm watching my homes he ain't going
away
brady's probably not going away brady
got to
pick a roster
like what am i doing in seattle
playing in games where it's you know 19
to 13 with two minutes to go when they
want me to win the game
let me go and have some fun
and i i think because of that weekend
and i even said to him i said man you
looked miserable because he did
and then all of a sudden i brought up a
stat i said man i was looking that
you've been sacked on an average of 43
times per game
every year he's like
and then all of a sudden he opened the
door and and
russell wilson doesn't open the door
when you interview him it's really rare
and all of a sudden
i i caught myself saying
wait
do you want to be traded
he goes well i don't know and i went
okay now we're having an interview now
this conversation now got real yeah
and then i just thought all right let me
go
let me see how far he'll let me go in
there
because
i was sort of reinforcing what he
already probably believed that why am i
out there getting sacked 45 times a game
and
you know they they want me to win these
games um and maybe you have a coach who
wants to have the running game and
another legion of boom and it just
doesn't work but there are those moments
when during an interview you go
oh wow okay we got something here that's
scottie pippen when scottie pippen was
on my word and
i because people
when scotty had the comments
about kevin durant and he's just talking
about kevin durant and criticizing kevin
durant which i thought okay scotty if he
wants to criticize i mean he's an
analyst or
and then he started talking about the
tony kuch play and phil
wanted tony basically to take the live
shot because tony's white
and i'm thinking nobody nobody is
picking up on this they want to get the
kevin durant part of this i go he's
calling phil jackson a racist
and i said get
scotty on
because i want to ask him
and then when i asked him i said are you
calling phil jackson a racist he said
yes
and then
sometimes you get these answers a lot of
times you ask questions you know what
the answers are at least you have an
idea yeah that's one of those where i
went oh wow you just called phil jackson
a racist now it's on in terms of you
having to be on your p's and q's and
also continue the conversation in a way
where
you know um
it doesn't go off the rails you know
because it could potentially go off the
rails there uh well i didn't want to
because if you don't push back or you
don't also
delve into it a little bit more now you
own it you know like that's part of the
interviewing
well even when i said well phil
had steve or you know mike michael
jordan you know deferred to steve kerr
for the last shot in the utah you know
utah game he goes oh michael did that
for the cameras
so he's saying michael
purposely
wanted steve kerr to take the jumper
from the foul line because the cameras
were on him with that documentary and i
go
wow this is this is deep
and and so i was trying to help scotty
there because i thought i don't know if
he knows what he's saying right and for
years covering those you know nba finals
we didn't talk to scotty that much it'd
be phil
or or michael
after a game yeah we didn't have scotty
i mean scotty sort of got lost nobody
knew his thoughts on anything yeah yeah
and
and now he's getting his
victory tour if you want to call it
but it just
it did i don't know i hate seeing it
because
you know you had this yeah you had
something special
and
keep that
hold on to that right you know michael's
not your friend michael wasn't anybody's
friend
just michael you already knew this but i
think scotty getting embarrassed in the
documentary and then that was it he was
done and i do understand that if you're
mike you know scottie pippen you're
watching that documentary
and you're thinking hey kids mike's
going to say some nice things about my
god and i mean how crushing would that
be beyond crushing crushing and i think
that that that was the breaking point
for scotty but you get these athletes
sometimes
and you don't know
if they're going to give you an honest
answer so my question for you dan
patrick is which one
do you prefer
where you get
that news breaking moment
that is
wild and you know you have to realize it
in the moment
um and you know for the lack of better
phrase
deal with that or
somebody paying fealty to qualcomm
or
kyler murray not answering the question
and you know that's going to go viral as
well
dan
this is your sports talk radio moment
you have to choose you can't just behind
the fence like which one when you get
something that's truly honest like kyler
murray was just awkward
it was just it became
like i was i was waiting for ashton
kutcher to come out and say you've been
punked and i you got me
are you are you saying that the dark
knight was not paying fuel tea to
qualcomm at the uh during that interview
years ago
okay so
we we booked matt hart
and
here we go he's got
surgery he's coming back you know
whatever and and i was like i'll try
matt harvey i've never had him on before
i have him on and
i started asking questions
and then
he didn't want to talk about his injury
he goes i'll talk about it some other
time i'm i'm just here to honor
qualcomm
you know i go
what
and i i thought oh wait i this cannot be
happening
so i said you know how this works matt
like you know
i ask you questions and then give you
the opportunity to talk about what
you're promoting and you understand i
don't think he'd done many interviews
hang up the phone pr person is calling
fritzy we're gonna have him back on
tomorrow and then i that exploded it was
like crazy
and
that one was i i felt bad because
sometimes these guys don't realize the
quid pro quo
but um if you said uh something in the
moment honest in the moment
russell wilson because russ doesn't do
that
and when he when he did it
then i realized that you know all you
want is somebody to give you the opening
sure
and if they do then you can do a good
interview because somebody say oh you
know you ask great questions right i
said no it's do i get great answers
because my question could be great
but if your answer's not great then is
it a great question and i guess to bring
it all full circle here um is that if
let's just say
stafford wins and the part the reason
why he wins this week is because he did
in fact decide i'm going to go for it
and leave my situation and that was
inspired by brady
and russell wilson was inspired by brady
to start thinking about maybe i should
go somewhere else maybe stafford would
be the next
piece of evidence for him or for rogers
or for maybe what's going on with kylo
murray the unfollowing people right now
it's kind of crazy that brady two years
ago might be a seismic event unless joe
burrow says i'm the next brady so
here we go like that in a way is super
bowl 56 what we're seeing play out writ
large maybe well i think if stafford
wins the super bowl and performs well
he'll go to the hall of fame
if joe burrow wins a super bowl he's
halfway to the hall of fame
you win another one you're in the hall
of fame
so you look at it from
sort of the top of the christmas tree
down
start with the quarterbacks and and the
importance of that and i think
if joe burrow in his second year wins
the super bowl so now all of a sudden
you've leapfrogged quite a few of these
quarterbacks
and
now you're in a conversation with
josh allen patrick mahomes
and rightfully so yes but i wondered i
asked peter king about this if we voted
at the end of the year on the mvp
and the bengals won and he said joe
burrow would be your mvp
yeah
right yes of course yeah
i wonder if we had votes on mvps at the
end of seasons all seasons right
baseball basketball football to include
the whole thing how how different it
would be because i always voted for
jordan for mvp
every year well i just said i'm voting
for michael and i had
barkley win it and carl malone went and
i had the fans and their media and those
cities going how can you do that you
know barkley had a better year or carl
malone did i said but michael's going to
win the championship
it was really easy you have legs
he's the mvp
because he's going to win the nba
championship they go wait you don't know
that i go
that's what i'm banking on that's value
so what's your pick for the super bowl
um
i i don't i can't see the rams losing a
game at home
but
uh i i would like to see the bengals win
so kid from ohio everybody yeah you know
what it's a big deal i mean you know
those those people been through a lot
they they you know it's an organization
that doesn't spend money
uh
you know they they usually hire coaches
on the cheap but they finally found
their quarterback and if you think back
how many franchises have kenny anderson
boomer sias and
joe bro carson palmer like those are
four franchise quarterbacks that you got
right uh and kenny anderson to me is a
borderline hall of famer
they've had those things they just
haven't that that surrounding group and
you'll hear from chris collinsworth
today he'll tell you jamar chase
he thinks will be one of the great wide
receivers of all time and the greatest
bengal wide receiver of all time already
but
you're going to win and lose this game
because of your offensive line
i mean i think that the rams approach
will be like tampa bay's approach to
kansas city last year we're just here we
come here we go deal with us and you
know they're going to put as much
pressure on joe burrow as possible and
you know do you try to can you survive
nine sacks again and i
i just don't see that happening but i it
would be a wonderful story
if joe wins in the in the bengals dp
thanks for coming here i will be on your
show tomorrow to complete the home and
home go ahead just touch the side you
should touch the trophy
i had a burrito earlier
all right
[Music]
hey are we gonna take my shirt off
tonight you take your pants off tonight
collins on hold right now saying what is
happening
all right is that a yes or no yeah i
think it was night one in that super
bowl yes it was yeah we have to
well let's talk
all right
i'll see you thank you buddy
everybody
we'll be on dance show tomorrow every
day from 9 a.m to noon eastern hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here